here's the thing we learn at like all
these good cops just gonna all step up
and do the right thing together please
most people don't do the right thing for
the right reason they do the right thing
for the right price
I promise you if you started giving cops
a hundred thousand to snitch on other
cops they will be arresting each other
at roll call you wouldn't make it at the
police station in the morning put your
hands up Sanchez
something's going on don't know how they
explained it things are just different
around the department
[Music]
that's not my mind I planted that
possession with intent come on I got a
family man cops are just going this
through the arms
you doing one yeah that's when they keep
playing evidence they just disappeared
or why you keep snitching on dirty cops
I'll keep an
[Music]
I know this much whoever doing all this
snitching can't be happy with himself
I'm found to drop my name normally no no
no Bernie it's not drug money just like
you brought drug money into my house a
decision okay
I salute some dirty cops i snitched on
Taylor Jenkins
Gavin etic i snitched on jimmy do their
work in the parking deck they play they
good money to do it
they pay you this much to snitch I
wasn't gonna tell you because I was
afraid of losing you are y'all hiring
[Music]
you know what you getting yourself into
cops'll go against the force to do the
right thing aren't rewarded by the
department to punish no promotions
assigned to the worst neighborhoods and
here life is on the line you did today
no backup snitches on the wrong
oh he wanted to go once oh yeah
I tell you this much if I find out who
snitched I'm gonna kill his a I'm which
on that bruh babe I bought two new black
stallions what's all this about she
under covered the horse track cool
alright basically y'all later
[Music]
that was close
I can't you're at the table okay
[Music]
you